with all the songs you have does any do
any bands ever approach you or or even
um classic artists who aren't really
doing that much writing of their own
anymore do any of them ever contact you
and say hey write me a song or would you
would you lend me a song no I think it's
such a touchy it's on a maybe on like
smaller levels or something but big
level artists it's like there's so much
it's not I don't even know if ego is the
word there's a lot of
you know it's like it's I wouldn't ask
someone you know it feels personal very
personal but I'm I mean I'm sure it
happens yeah but like like Rihanna with
us but let me ask you Rihanna uh hashia
writes songs for her like why does no
one say to you listen you're such a
prolific songwriter and and you
obviously have the touch I mean the
magic of making hits
I'm surprised no one ever says to you
hey
I started as a songwriter as a ghost
writer in fact so before the band
happened I was doing ghost writing for
for pop stars but I um did you have any
hits did you ever love doing that did
you have any hits with the pop star no I
mean Define hits I will I've had
I've had some songs one of one of which
that I'm a Ghostwriter on that I can't
say that did well no kidding you mean
your name's not on the credit it's a
really complex situation no yeah I'm uh
it's really complex this is something I
I will tell you that author I'll tell
you okay yeah and this artist hired you
to come in and write and or bought a
song of yours and said yeah I don't want
yeah
does that drive you crazy as an artist
because that's your baby
no no that was that's more just like
making money for the family you know I
mean I don't I don't see it as that um
I wasn't like I was writing a song they
were like write a song about this so
it's not for me I'm not thinking you
know what I mean I wouldn't I wouldn't
give a song away if I felt like it was
that you know geez that's an amazing
story
I can't imagine why you can't I mean I
understand you can't say it from a legal
aspect yeah I didn't put my name on it
because I did not want to be a part of
it that's the short of it that's like me
giving you the the
is it a song I would recognize from an
artist I would recommend maybe yeah
oh my God that's fantastic I mean that's
just I wonder what else
do you have no I don't hate the song I
don't hate the song I just it had I just
didn't want to be a part of it did you
ever drive around and hear it on the
radio or anything and then go oh wait a
second that's my song yeah yeah wow
foreign
this is crazy I gotta hang with you guys
anytime anytime come to Vegas whenever